okay so we come back to my hometown of
Dublin to the Science Gallery because
they have an exhibit on at the minute
about the elements and the reason that I
am particularly interested is that
they've got a big bunch of periodic
tables as you know we love periodic
tables so we're going to go in and see
what these tables look like
okay so we've got here a periodic table
in Braille which is actually I think
pretty cool this is hydrogen after that
this is the rest of the elements
I don't read Braille at all this is I
like this one I do like this one this is
a periodic table well it's laid out like
a site test check I've seen lots of
these in my time because I'm a poor
eyesight so I've read lots of sight
tests but it's really good it gets
really small down here Oh stand back
there technetium now can't see that
so what this does is it's weighing me
and then it takes the average amount of
different elements in a person then it's
going to tell me how many atoms of each
element they're actually in my body okay
so the highlights I'm mostly oxygen 40
warm point 9 to 5 kilos of oxygen and
I've got one point five eight by ten to
the twenty seven atoms of oxygen in my
body it's a long list
we've got radium we've got six point
five by ten to the minus twenty ish
grams of radio we've got one point seven
by 10 to the seven atoms so still more
than a million atoms so that's me
that's what it takes to make me
this is a really nice representation of
the periodic table if you look back you
can actually see the shape of it and
what it's made out of are different
heating elements so it's actually made
of elements in this case heating
elements I walked that out as soon as I
saw it Brady didn't Brady's a little bit
slow well it's nice isn't it I don't
like the fact that they're all the same
material as we know the periodic table
is obviously made of different elements
these appear to be all pretty similar
heating elements and I like the shape of
it it's cold I don't think you
understand the way I feel about the
skull I really like this what we've got
here is we've got an exhibit on the
periodic table and what the organizers
have done is they've asked members of
the public to bringing samples of
different elements so it started off
empty with just these boxes labeled with
different elements you know look at some
of my favorite ones I'm gonna go over
here really like this one not here
somebody brought in some radium blades
double edged blades for shaving with
radium so years ago people thought
radium was the cure for everything and
they put it into products such as
toothpaste and things like that whether
or not these blades have any radium
that's the trademark I don't know what
we got here we've got a sodium salt we
know what that is we have a joke about
sodium somebody brought in I like this
one they don't he could sodium gels
lately now these are moldy looking
bananas this is pretty cool actually and
the titanium exhibit somebody brought in
an x-ray of their leg showing titanium
pins where it's this which are stitching
their broken leg together I like that
we've got an old iron an actual iron
iron which is pretty cool selenium
Brazil nuts good source of selenium
apparently so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna make an addition to this
periodic table and I actually like these
elements down here all of these boxes
hassium meitnerium those stadium these
are all empty so what I'm gonna add is a
card which shows the professor and Brady
in Darmstadt at the laboratory where
they actually made them strata and the
reason that I want to have this one is
darmstadtium is it quite obviously quite
a rare element and I doubt if any member
of the public is going to be able to
bring a sample along to put into the
exhibit so this card is probably the
closest we can get anyway
- have I written my name the element is
time stadium and this is a photo showing
professor Polyakov at the GSI Darmstadt
where time stockings isolated okay so
there we go so we've added to the
periodic table